e
good morning welcome to
Edna opening the public hearing on House
Traer good morning Madam chair and
members of
Edna I am representative Douglas traia
belnap County District 8 representing
the towns of Belmont mon Tilton and
samton today I come before you with
house bill um
622 um after doing some more research um
looking into I support the idea here I
think there's um a couple of concerns so
I'm going to ask this committee at this
bill okay thank you
that's a reasonable request
Madam chair I would just like to point
out um for other legislators that may be
watching on YouTube or this is exactly
how you do that when something goes a
muck don't try to plug a boat that's got
10,000 holes in it right and just
recognize what's going on and and let us
get onto other business so thank you
representative trer for that yes thank
um Mr C on Miss crion since I believe we
will be killing the bill do you feel the
need to
I'm uh probably yes or at least some of
them
okay I'm not sure I heard the reason
which just too many issues too many
issues yes all right I will settle for
that does anyone else wish to speak on
622 all right repres Mr bodri waves
off okay in that
case I will close the public hearing we
will go into executive session does
someone have a
motion representative Schmidt I
okay representative Schmidt moves ID itl
representative Leon seconds do you wish
motion B the request of the
sponsor move okay represent L um same
reason
okay does anyone else wish to comment
questions all right seeing none the
motion is inexpedient to legislate on
622 and the clerk can call the
role Vice chairman Lou
yes yes represent pearon yes
representative Bailey
I representative Shen
yes representative sers yes
representative yes
represento yes representative yes
yes representative Howard yes
representative Dar
yes
representative long
yes chair yes
14 okay the motion passes 14 to
Z to and is there any objection to
consent all
right while we are in um executive
session I believe represent L has a
motion to retain um yes Madam chair um I
would like to to move to retain House
Bill 349 which is the opthalmologic
laser bill I'll be happy to second that
okay yes if you'd like to speak to your
motion yes thank you madam chair uh this
is an issue that's been uh worked on
over the previous year and we need to
give them a little bit more time it
seems that the opthalmologists are doing
a good job of getting increased service
and coverage up in the north country and
the optometrist would like to have some
more time to make sure that they can
make clear to us what's what training
standards would be required for um
somebody to perform these opthalmologic
laser procedures uh given that this is
an opportunity for them to get us more
information I think it makes sense for
us to retain the bill um rather than to
proceed
now repr
Pearson that was uh eloquently stated
and exactly what I was thinking
excellent does anyone else have
questions comments
concerns representative
Schmidt I I absolutely agree that this
is uh better for us to retain as
indicating uh that we have a concern
about this issue but uh in my belief uh
this should be worked out by the
profession not by the legislature
exactly and it I would agree with that
they should they should be working it
out all right any other comments for the
power no
okay all right in that case the motion
is to retain House Bill
349 and the clerk can call the
role when no
Russ Vice chairman Le
yes yes representative yes
representative b
i representative sh yes representative
sers yes representa SL yes
representative tibo yes yes
representative
Groen yes representative Schmid yes
representative yes representa Howard yes
representative long yes
yes okay vote to retain does not have to
be on the calendar we just reported so
no question of consent and U that will
we will be awaiting information from the
affected parties and work on it over the
summer all
right does anyone else have something
on I do need to go get an amendment from
uh the fourth floor so if we have time
we we've got 20 minutes now
um Madam chair I'm just wondering if
there's anything from the building code
subcommittee meeting that
I'm not sure that we're ready to exec
any of those bills but I'm just asking
about
that there was one that uh we could
retain vote to retain okay and that was
um H the other two are still in work
244 and that's
the the is that Municipal Amendment um
that is updating and Rec codifying the
municipal enforcement of the building
and fire codes that's the recodification
okay definitely want to retain that one
yeah so that was the 2425 page bill that
needs more eyes to to look at it and um
make sure everything's in
motion okay and I'll just add that Rec
rectifying the statutes is is a is a
good idea needs to be done every now and
then but you it does need very careful
scrutiny to make sure you
don't looking out
for unanticipated
represent any other comments
questions all right seeing then that the
motion is to retain House Bill
ready we also we had a oneline Amendment
that that's in currently in OS being uh
drafted don't need to address the
amendment if you're going to retain
okay represent Vice chairman lamb yes
yes represent
out represent Bailey I representative
Sheen yes representative
sers oh sorry represent SL yes
representative
TBO
yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative Dar yes representative
Howard yes representative de re yes uh
representative long yes
the chair
yes
four8 10 13 zero to retain okay we will
keep hold of that
one all right Madam chair I have a
question on House Bill 214 is that going
to this is the one on the regulations of
the recreational therapist and
Respiratory Care practitioners and this
was at the request of oplc was this sent
to um subcommittee I don't have any
we U I need to get an amendment that
addresses the language for the criminal
so anyone else have something that they
think is
ready all right in that case we come out
of executive session and we will the the
far
e
okay welcome
back opening the public hearing on House
Bill 534 and I call Representative Steve
Pearson who
is introducing it at at the request of
good morning Edna committee for the
record I am Representative Steve Pearson
Rockingham District 13 which encompasses
the town of dairy I was asked by the
prime sponsor to introduce this bill
because he is conducting a funeral right
now um at the request of the Prime in
the group that brought this forward uh
some things have been learned as far as
the processing and there was a little
bit of misunderstanding as to what is
currently occurring so the at their
request um we asked this bill also be
killed and ited as um the bill does not
do what was intended to
questions seeing n thank you for your
testimony
all
right Mr bodri do you wish to
speak
okay um right is there anyone else who
wishes to speak on House Bill
534 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing and we will go into executive
session uh representative Pearson I'd
like to make a motion on House Bill 534
is there a
second representative Lon
seconds all right um as was stated in
the introduction um there is
a technical problem with the bill and as
well as there is a uh there was a bit of
a misunderstanding as to how things were
operating so in the interest of not
making things worse or causing confusion
uh it is best to to do away with it R
blon he said what I was thinking thank
you excellent does anyone else have
concerns all right seeing none the
motion is an inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill
534 and the clerk can call the
role chman L
yes yes representative peon yeses baile
I
Vanessa she representative she yes
representative sers is not
represent yes represento yes
representative
representa yes representative
Howard stepped out out also uh
representative re yes representative
yes I'll move consent Madam
chair is there are there any objections
to
consent seeing none we'll put this one
on consent representative Pearson at
convenience all
right and you have have another motion
for us I do Madam chair I have another
motion I'd like to introduce to House
Bill
233 amendment
163h that you all should have in front
of
you so all right so that they we have an
amendment to House Bill
233 do you wish to speak to the motion
oh first of all is there a second second
second by representative Lon
do wish to speak to your motion yes
thank you madam chair
um one of the things that I think we
took from the public hearing on this
was two things one I think there was a
little bit of a misunderstanding as to
exactly what this organization does
which I appreciate the clarity of of
straightening some of that
out um I think they made made it
abundantly clear that
the overwhelming majority of the
questions that they take really have
nothing to do with them so uh looking at
the original Bill uh I think it's it's
prudent that the request that
they answer questions that really have
nothing to do with them and post and go
through this whole process was really
just
unnecessary uh and too burdensome but on
the flip side of
that in 2025 the idea that a meeting
that is electronically created then gets
transcribed into minutes like it's 1920
is also weird and I think with a little
bit of a you know some of the testimony
with those that are in a perhaps
different generational category than
some of us we see that you know they
really would rather prefer just to click
on the meeting and watch it so I think
that that request Quest is is certainly
reasonable um it is a very inexpensive
thing to do and frankly we'll save them
from having someone to type up a set of
minutes so that is the the gist of this
amendment it simply just removes the
requirement in section
B okay
BL um thank you madam chair um while
this is a public private partnership a
lot of what they execute um regards
contract with the federal government and
other things that really directly impact
the lives of people in New Hampshire and
the transparency of how that is
implemented I think is critical to make
sure that people understand what is
happening in the state and that they're
able to be up to date on these policies
because um quite frankly some of the
policies from the New Hampshire uh
vaccine Association um we've heard from
pediatricians that that's a reason why
they are not no longer accepting certain
patients in their practice this likely
is an issue at the DC level and not at
the New Hampshire level but having
transparency and seeing what's happening
in those meetings and exactly what
they're doing allows people to know
where to focus their efforts and
understand why they're being denied
care representative G thank you I have a
question for well I wanted to discuss it
with the committee I don't believe that
a video is an official Rec is an
official uh document of the meeting I
know that in our town we have to have
meeting minutes on file for all of our
organiz for all of our meetings so I
don't believe that in this case this
would alleviate the New Hampshire
vaccination board from transcribing
their
meetings as a private entity I'm not
aware of the requirement that they keep
minutes and the other is that this is a
501c3 organization and I don't know of
any other 501c3 organizations that we um
do this for I don't mind the committee
setting a part policy but this is not
policy setting in my view this is
picking a specific
organization and if we're going to if
this is important to us we should be
doing this to all entities in New
Hampshire so P that perhaps we want to
change the bill to reflect that I'll be
voting against this amendment because I
don't don't think that just picking on
one group is helpful if that's our
Quest okay anyone else comment
representative citech uh a couple points
uh with respect to representative groda
I think we can make as a legislature
anything we want to be official and I
don't think any the video recording
could just is uh could be defined to be
by the legislature as official as
anything else I think minutes are almost
an
the second point is I'll vote for the
amendment because I think think it
improves the bill but I'll vote against
the bill on the basis that this is a not
this is not a public body this is a pass
through organization doing
administrative tasks and well it might
be nice to do it I don't think we have
the business to impose this requirement
on them so uh I'm I'll vote against the
the
concerns okay the motion is to adopt
Amendment
0163 H to House Bill 233 and the clerk
can call the
rule Vice chairman Leon yes votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey I representative
Sheen yes
representative SL
yes uh representative Debo yes
Representative groda no representative
Schmidt
no
representative Dary
no representative
Howard still not here not in the room
repres Rees
no and represented La no
chair yes two four six
eight eight to five to adopt the
amendment okay we have adopted the
amendment 8 to five representative
Pearson you have a
motion yes Madam chair I'll move um
autop pass is amended on House Bill
second any disc do you wish to speak to
the amendment is a in essence a rewrite
a full rewrite so what is what has
already been said I think suffices as
it's the same thing okay represent
concerns all right seeing none the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on House Bill 233 and the clerk can call
the
role representative Leon yes uh clerk
votes no representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey I representative
she yes representative
SL yes representative
TBO yes Representative broa no
representative Schmidt no representative
Davis is not here Representative darg no
representative
Howard not here either sorry
representative degrees no represent long
no and the chair
six7 that's six yeah
76 in in favor of theot of the motion
the motion passes 7 to six it will not
be on
consent does anyone want to write a
Minority Report okay representative GR
okay anything else we should
do in executive
session I don't think we have any of the
Amendments that we're working on so I'll
close the executive session we will
resume the public hearing
te
e
good
morning be before I open the hearing on
House Bill 536 representative scitec has
an
announcement uh this has to do with a
conflict of interest in this bill and in
general actually microphone I think I
have it on the uh we're all familiar
with the conflict of interest procedure
and the Declaration of intent uh that no
Declaration of intent isn't required if
something of legislation does not affect
affect you to a greater extent than to
any other member of such a business um
that's familiar language and we file a
declaration of intent form that says we
will participate or not participate but
sixa this I'm reading from the U ethics
guidelines recusal for conflicts of
interest and B says uh the legislator or
a member of legislator's household could
reasonably be expected to incur direct
and substantial benefit or detriment as
a result of the outcome because this is
a cola which would affect me as a member
of the group one uh basically for the
rest of my life that sounds like it's
direct and substantial so as I read this
thing there's sort of a there is a
conflict I believe in the in the
conflict procedure and um I'm going to
I think I am going to recuse myself
especially since I'm in no one of the
committee Ethics
Committee
bye Al I don't believe he's banished
Madam chair I yes I not he just I
believe you said you were going to be
taking notes oh yeah okay fine
he will be taking notes but he will not
be sitting with the committee and he
will not be voting on this bill if we
choose to vote on so representative grod
is the prime
sponsor thank you madam chair my name is
Jacki groda and I'm the state
representative for the town of Ry in
Greenland on the
coast I um sponsor I'm sponsoring this
bill which asks the legislature to issue
a cost of living adjustment to those
members of the retirement system some of
you who were here for our retirement
system presentation at the beginning of
this session in
orientation may have reviewed their the
presentation slides last night as I did
and I wanted to um point to slide number
23 which outlines the number of
individuals under each
category each pay category
also on slide 22 it describes the groups
one and two retirement
retirees and the average salary that
they get as a retirement and the average
for all
retirees and this bill asks that a 1 and
a half% cola be given to individuals who
make up to
$50,000 and for those individuals who
make more than that the cola would be
1.5% for the first
$50,000 and just for those of you who um
are ask are wondering how much that is
$750 which to me is a small amount
to be compensated for for the increases
in household goods that we've all
experienced
um this is a policy committee and you
are making a decision on the policy as
to whether or not the retirees should be
getting a cola and not the financial
policy because this bill goes to finance
this bill has passed this commission
this committee
before and um several times actually and
when it has
reached Finance what they've chosen to
give instead of the one 1 and a half% is
a
stiped so that the financial impact is
less than the one that's outlined in
this
bill the latest stiens in 2022 and 2023
were
$500 so I wanted to um I'm I support
this bill I support um you know I
support the families that work um for
and have the retirement system as their
benefit package and it's uh important
that Gran stators feel that there's
somebody who's listening to them when it
comes to their monetary requirements for
their household and with that I'd like
to close my testimony because there are
several people who wish to speak in
favor of The
Spill and to make things oh you have a
question representative Schmid do you
have a question I do Madam chair thank
you do you know what the cost would be
to the retirement
system uh terminally funding
this this is funded through State
contributions because remember um
municipalities pay into the retirement
system so this is paid for by the
providers it's not paid for by the
retirement system itself so the
municipalities would pay as well as the
state do but do you follow up follow up
schmi the retirement system is going to
speak next and they have the real data
on the on the numbers and I think they'd
be a better person to answer your
question I certainly would ask them but
I thought maybe the sponsor
knows thank you okay other questions
thank you representative
good afternoon I'm Mark kavar Deputy
counsel and compliance officer for the
uh New Hampshire retirement system and
with me is Diana kryon she's our
hearings examiner she's an attorney as
well and she's helping to fill in the
gaps and uh support us uh while we're
appointed I'm here today just
to just to speak to the
funding um I understand that the
committee just was made available the
the fiscal notice prepared by
LBA and there's two components to the
cost of this we take no policy position
on whether cost of living is good or bad
that's a policy decision for the
committee but we want to point out that
there are
annual uh
expenditures uh starting in 2028 as
would be reflected in the contribution
rates
um of 1.5 million for the state and 6.6
million for the political
subdivisions and uh that's um how
the uh rates would be affected by this
going forward primarily an increase in
the normal cost
cost uh for for new employees as you or
for retirees as you figure that in um
the other aspect of this is that the
bill provides that it shall be
terminally funded from the state annuity
accumulation fund and that's that I I
just wanted to be careful that that's
not misleading because the state annuity
accumulation fund is us we have a member
annuity accumulation fund which is made
of of member cont contributions in in in
their interest they get allocated then
we have the state annuity accumulation
fund which is employer contributions and
Investments earnings and so this is
unfunded it's not terminally funded
because it's not providing any outside
source of funds to pay for this and thus
this will increase our uh UA or unfunded
million and I'd open it up for
questions okay representative Lam um
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here to answer questions um
looking at this fiscal note it looks
that there'll be a cost to our um
political subdivisions of $6.6
million um in addition to basically
what's the unfunded cost to the state
does so looking at this bill that would
then mean that our municipalities um
that are having a hard time right now
with the same inflation would then need
to foot the bill for this would that be
correct right this is the uh you know
rates for the prior fiscal years have
been set so uh the next time rates will
be changed would be fiscal year
28 and this is the actuary's prediction
of what the increase total cost that
would be reflected in those rates would
be follow follow and as a followup do
you know if that would increase the
percentage that the employ that the
employers need to contribute to the
retirement system yes it would do you
know by how much or no right there oh
sorry my apologies I didn't do a good
job reading the fiscal note yeah on the
on the back side you can see uh what the
net impact of The Proposal as a percent
of payroll would be for each of the four
member groups for political Subs 15% for
employees 23 for teachers 05%
for employees. 23 for teachers 0 43 for
you anything else just a
curiosity the reason police and fire are
higher is Bec is that because they their
pensions are larger or is it because
they live longer after
retirement I I would this is yes I'm a
lawyer non
actuary
um the benefit caps at 50 but the
average group one benefit is in the low
20s there are more group twos who have
benefits in the 30s and 40s who would
receive a larger
amount of
cola thank you very much Madam chair I I
can also point out to your question that
police and fire are a much much smaller
subset so when you're yes I I'm well
running over a cost right you're
dividing it amongst the entities I was
just wondering about the difference okay
other questions from the retirement
system anyone I I have one representa
pear this is as we see these over the
years these are all stretched out over a
time frame and the 100.7 millionar is
the cost of stretching this over a
20-year period correct right it's the
present value cost of providing that
cost to live an increase over whatever
longterm period this to be paid for in
one shot what's that number $ 100.7
million so 100.7 then then I guess I'm
I'm confuses yeah it's either well if
it's in one shot if it's $1.7 million in
one shot which seems a atrociously high
to me for an immediate payment over 20
years it can't be
100.7 no it's the presid value so the
increase in the U is the present value
of paying everyone else up to
$750 a month a year more for the rest of
their
lives okay so you bring that down to a
present value if you want to pay for it
all now you pay that present value
because we'd have the 100.7 million and
we'd invest it and have those investment
earnings to to because the real dollar
amount you added up over the next 30
Years is way more you're just counting
it I got you okay that you answered
thank you okay all right other
repres uh if I I want to make sure I
understand the the financial side of
this um so how I how I Envision this
working is that it brings in the
ultimate zero date for the pension
system so that whatever money we're
saving whatever date that runs out if we
don't address the um the the outstanding
liability that that date would be sooner
because of this if this bill were to
pass uh not necessarily so if you're
increasing the unfunded liability by
$100
million uh the next time that rates
employer rates are set in two years the
actual would take into account that it's
larger and then would uh concominant
increase the employer contributions
towards the UA to make that
payment uh to bring the U Down
theoretically to zero under our current
plan which is
2039 so it all all gets worked into the
numbers over time
we a few years back we took the existing
UA and locked it in to end in
2039 and every two years there after we
look at all the changes and say all
right that's an extra
50 million plus 20 million minus or
whatever
and uh amortise that over up to 20 years
which in practice means 20 years so this
would be an increase that would start in
28 and go on to 48
yeah thank you that that that's correct
Madam chair that this additional
liability we have layered amortization
the first layer was our original plan
for for what it was in 2010 or 11 to
bring that down to Zero by
2039 you have subsequent changes that
can be due to Le uh unfunded legislation
such as this or changes in actual
assumptions or maybe a really bad
investment Year and that additional
unfunded amount is then in a separate
layer that's advertised over 20 years so
we currently have two layers this would
create a third layer that we'd amortize
that 100 million over 20 years yes and
that would be again reflected in the
rates and if we manage to go two years
without increasing the UA and have a
very good investment year we might
actually have a negative layer of
amortisation
yes um not we'll see it when it happens
anyone else
yes representative Tio thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question I was just wondering um how
would this um Bill impact that 2039 goal
or
deadline uh it it would not affect the
deadline it would affect employer
rates the next time we'd have that
separate layer and then we'd have to say
how do we amortise that 100 million over
the next 20 years the 2039 date was to
uh amortize
the unfunded liability as it existed
when that uh date was established in two
I believe it was 2010 or 11
um and then each subsequent change in
the UA is advertised over 20
years this would mean that in if every
everything else was Zero the bulk of UA
would be paid off in 39 but this slice
48 okay other
questions all right thank you very much
for the information thank you for the
opportunity to
thank you madam chairman I want to wish
everybody a Happy New Year this is the
first time I'm testifying before this
committee uh this year anyways happy New
Year and congratulations on your
elections uh for Madame chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is Arthur bodry I represent the New
Hampshire State permanent firefighters
retirement Association I'm a retired
captain from the Manchester fire
department and I sat on the Board of
Trustees of the New Hampshire retirement
system for 13 years I am here to speak
in favor of house bill
536 the last true Cola that was granted
in the past 15 years was in 2019 it was
a 1 a half% cost of living adjustment
based on the first $50,000 of retirement
similar to this piece of legislation the
cost of living based on the CPU for that
same time period has increased by
38.6% while retirees received a 1 and a
half% cost of living adjustment cost of
living adjustments in New Hampshire
retirement system have been far and few
between since 2000 2010 Most states that
surround us provide an annual cost of
living increase to their retirees it is
difficult to maintain the rising cost of
inflation without an adequate cost of
living adjustment uh just to answer a
couple of the questions that were asked
to Prior speakers um first of all police
and fire uh fire live less than the
normal population
um they actually use a different
mortality table for the retirement
system for firefighters because of our
life expectancy um secondly uh cost of
living raises when the system was
developed in 1967 they were granted
similar to what this legislation is
doing from ' 67 to 83 before they
started the special account they would
Grant the cola uh back then the legisl
Met every other year so they would Grant
the 2-year Cola and it would the
retirement system would just Bild
each department uh town or city for
their members that were impacted with
that cost of living rise then in 28 uh
in uh 1983 when the special account was
developed for SP cost of living raises
the municipal Association and others
were in favor of that because they
didn't like getting those bills every
other year uh to pay for their retirees
they felt this was going to be a cost
savings to them hav come out of a
special account and that went on until
20 2 when they eliminated the special
account and the only way now to get a
cost of living raise is through enabling
legislation like this to Grant uh colas
um and one other point I would like to
make group two does not pay into Social
Security so the cost of living from the
retirement system is really the main
stay of what retired firefighters earn
live off of U they don't have social
security uh where group one does so
that's the difference between how it was
and how it is today and I will take any
questions thank you are there a
questions seeing none thank you very
good morning Madame chair women and
members of the House executive
departments and administrative committee
for the record my name is Richard gulla
I'm honored to be representing over
10,000 hardworking New Hampshire public
employees and retirees of the state
employees
Association I'm here today to ask your
support on House Bill 536 relative to a
cost of living adjustment in the state
retirement system this bill grants a
cost of living adjustment to any retired
member in the New Hampshire retirement
system who has been retired for at least
60 months prior to July 1
2025 or to any beneficiary of a retiree
who is receiving an
allowance the supplemental allowance
would be 1.5% of the first $50,000 of
retired member or benefici beneficiaries
allowance and payable beginning on the
retired Member's First anniversary date
occurring on or after July 1
2026 the supplemental allowance will
become a permanent addition to the
beneficiary's base retirement allowance
and shall be terminally fronted from the
state annuity accumulation fund you may
recall the legislature passed similar
legislation House Bill 616 in 2019 the
only difference being it was for those
who were retired for 60 months prior to
July 1 2019
19 our members are participants of the
New Hampshire retirement system we are
the men and women who plow our roads
ensure we have clean water to drink and
that our children are safe and our
elderly are cared for we are your
neighbors we are your friends we are
dedicated public servants who have
helped build New Hampshire and continue
to keep New Hampshire great today we are
here asking for your help as you know
the cost of living is gone up for all
Americans but especially for older
americ Americans who have higher medical
costs dental and prescription drug
expenses which often rise faster than
the general rate of
inflation Rising prices in inflation can
quickly erode the value of one's
retirement's income even a modest rate
of inflation significally impacts
purchasing power over time from March
2020 to 24 the CPI for food at home had
risen by
24.7% outpacing the 20.3% increase
observed to across other CPI categories
this equates to roughly a 25% overall
increase in the cost of grocery store
items compared to just four years ago
simply put our pensions are not keeping
up with inflation many current retirees
are forced to make some very very
difficult decisions as their pension
values
decrease that's why I'm here today
asking for your help historically before
1983 cost of living adjustments were
funded each budget year through the
state operating budget the legislator
passed House Bill 500 in 1983 which
created the special account the special
account was funded through excess
earnings from the retirement system in
excess of a half perc over the rate of
return the funds in the special account
were used to pay for colas ranging from
anywhere from 1 to 5% as determined by
the
legislature this special account was
closed in 2012 and the remaining monies
were transferred into the Corpus of the
fund now the legislature by Statute
decides whether a cola is given and how
much is granted there is no builtin
which puts the retirement security of
thousands of retirees solely in the
hands of the
legislature that's why we're here today
urging you to pass House Bill
536 retirement security is something
every employee deserves after a long
successful career in public service New
Hampshire retirees have dedicated their
working life to helping our state run
every day and have earned a benefit that
should allow them to retire with dignity
in exchange for a lifetime of service
our retired employees deserve a Divine
defined and predictable retirement
security that is protected against
inflationary pressures HB 536 helps with
that security and that's why we ask for
your support ideally this bill would be
a step towards what used to be the norm
when retirees could expect a permanent
regular
Cola some may tell you today that we
need to wait on doing this I would
respond to that by saying we cannot
simply ask those members who cons
consistently paid into the system over
many years to continue to wait let's
make this permanent addition to a
retiree's pension a reality and show our
retirees they are not forgotten thank
you for your
time thank you Mr gulla are there any
questions seeing
morning Madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Brian will I the president of the
professional firefighters of New
Hampshire and we represent approximately
2,000 active and retired firefighters
throughout the Granite State uh I'm
going to be incredibly brief this
morning which I'm sure you're all happy
to hear um I'm going to speak to you
from more of a philosophical standpoint
less of a technical standpoint um we
support House Bill 536 for a number of
reasons uh primarily uh for our members
it it comes down to the fact that
they've felt the squeeze over the years
um with inflation being what it is uh
and the inability to have a steady cost
of living adjustment over that same
period of time um these are members that
um you know have served in 20 25 30e
careers and the fire service uh have put
their their health and their safety at
risk for those that they serve um and
you know in as a thanks for that we give
them um you know a fair uh pension but
that does not keep up with inflation as
we know it um as was mentioned earlier
these members do not pay into Social
Security thus they do not collect Social
Security from these positions um which
makes it far more difficult for them to
survive on um their retirement uh after
10 15 20 years of service um these are
members that are
also um in sending money back to our
Economy based on um you know
Approximately 80% of them stay within uh
the confines of New Hampshire after they
retire uh and if you look back on uh
Bureau of Labor Statistics a dollar 20
years ago is approximately a161 today um
in purchasing power and so I think we
need to consider the fact that we have
80% of our retirees remaining here in
New Hampshire um who are uh infusing
money back into the
state um the National Institute of
retirement security uh provides an
economic impact profile for each state
across the country uh and in 2021 they
concluded that for every dollar of
taxpayer contributions through employer
rates a net of
$610 of economic impact is made to the
New Hampshire economy uh which resulted
in 210 million uh paid back in federal
state and local taxes as well so these
are all contributing members of our um
society and our economy and uh again
they have not been provided with a fair
Cola over the years and I would like uh
this committee uh to look at the policy
aspect of this and determine whether or
not um you all think it's fair
uh for that to be the case and we'd ask
for your full support of this uh to send
it to the floor and subsequently to the
finance committee um with that I
recognize that there uh are a number of
retirement issues on the horizon uh I
appreciate this committee's uh due
diligence in taking a look at all of
this uh objectively and trying to be
fair to uh everyone that uh comes before
you and is looking for uh a fair shot at
a dignified retirement thank you and
I'll be happy to answer any questions
questions good
Shu good morning Madam chair and uh
members of Edna I will tell you um my
name is Diane Shu and uh I formerly
served on this committee for I think 11
years so I know this subject pretty well
uh I will tell you further that I was
the Prime sponsor of the only Cola bill
passed in recent memory in New Hampshire
that bill that passed in
2019 and the main reason I'm speaking in
support of this bill is because is like
this bill that bill that passed in
2019 had a five-year look back you will
see in the um number one paragraph
people who've been retired for 60 months
or five years do not are not eligible
for this that was the case in 2019 also
so I would point out to you that that
group of people that we excluded in
2019 have now been without a cola for
over 10 years so that's what we're
hoping this can
overcome that particular Bill uh in 2019
happily enjoyed the support of Governor
sonunu because he could see the benefit
to our public
retirees as well as the positive effect
on current Cent employees as we all know
that there's a retention difficulty for
people who work for public
entities uh I can tell you myself I
retired in 2005 I'm coming up on my 20y
year
anniversary and it gets tougher and
tougher to pay for my property taxes my
utilities the costs of food just
depending on my state pension
and Social Security uh I think we're all
aware that those have not been
sufficient to even meet the costs of
inflation um I will just further state
that these folks all mostly spent their
careers working for you and me either in
our communities or for the state and
most of them are retired in New
Hampshire so this money that comes to
their pockets are is going to be spent
in New Hampshire it's going to come back
into our economy to me that's a large
plus I think that's about all that I
have uh so that I'm not repeating what
other folks have said thank you very
much thank you are there any
questions
can you hear me yeah for the uh record
my name is Karen Irwin and I'm from the
town of hopkington
I've a testif IED on this bill many
times I'm a state retiree myself fairly
recently and
um so but would not qualify of course
um I want what I wanted to tell you is
that this bill's gone through many times
and the last in most recent memory it
turned into a stien I'm happy to hear
that you're looking at the policy behind
it and not the financial matters so much
so I hope you pass this on to the
finance
committee
um the uh fin the um retirement
system has had a good gain in the last
year according to the report and some of
those gains it would be nice if they
came back through and added to like a
cola fund i' like to not see us just pay
that $500 every time this comes up and
actually start building
something um when this when it was 85
million the last time this went through
instead of a 100 million um you know it
seemed like there ought to be a way to
build up a cola account or something and
at least move this forward in some way
where you build that forward and just
not end up being you know a stien again
uh because I guess the legislature can
see the benefit of doing this but it's a
that's a big number to crack so
um that was we have
45,3 emplo uh retirees right now and
um that way you know it would
hopefully it would probably be done by
some sort of committee that would
determine how much they could do out in
colas and close to a line to this so I
hope we do something we move this
forward in finance as well in some way
and not just that number is too scary to
crack so
um that's what I basically wanted to say
thank you very much for your testimony
are there any
questions well thank you good job is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
536 all right seeing none I'm going to
1:15
e
all right welcome back good afternoon
I'm opening the public hearing on House
Bill 637 and I call Representative
luno thank you very much Madam chair
members of the of the committee for the
record my name's uh Dave luno and I
represent Marmont County District nine
which are the folks that live in the
towns of Hopkinson bow but I always say
I never give up conquered it used to be
in my district and uh and with bills
like this in in fact all the bills we
talk about have statewide significance
so uh so that's also part of uh I think
all of our responsibilities so I'm here
to introduce House Bill
637 which is regarding the calculation
of State retirement annuities um as I
was just expressing to representative
Lon this is not an area of the law where
I feel like I'm any way an expert so I
think there's going to be people um that
coming that are coming after me that
have a much more um tangible and and and
you know a detailed you know background
in history in um in in the New Hampshire
retirement system and and uh and what
this uh specific Bill uh is trying to
accomplish but I can give you a quick
sort of high level 30,000 foot viewpoint
on it but uh three years ago the
legislature passed a bipartisan bill
that corrected a long overdue issue uh
with when at um uh group one members
pension is recalculated to around 10% a
10% reduction for the rest of their
retirement um uh years and the
legislature Rec IED at the time that um
65 years old was no longer the age at
which group one employees reached their
full Social Security age so there's some
there was some Gap uh I I guess that
that had existed and when the
legislature updated the law to reflect
one's full social social security age it
did not include a small slice of
employees who had already retired uh but
had not yet turned their full Social
Security age and so it's a closed group
this isn't a group that's getting any
bigger it's probably going the other way
um hopefully not very quickly but but uh
it's a closed group of retirees that
should have been included but we're not
and uh and that's really what I have for
Testimony to introduce the bill and uh
and hopefully uh any questions uh of any
any sort of technical nature can uh can
fall on the uh U people behind me here
thank you I do have one non-technical
question are have you seen the fiscal
fiscal note for this bill we haven't I I
I I have seen some numbers on that I
don't see that here but uh but I believe
the um uh actually a a constituent who
brought this to um to to my attention as
well as representative McDonald's
attention does have some fiscal Noe
information and uh and I think we'd be
happy to uh to I'm sure share that with
the committee okay thank thank
you thank you very much Mr Greenland do
you have the is the fiscal note
online okay do you think you could get
you could arrange to get us some copies
of
it all right uh I only have one other
Irwin what
surprise I have the fiscal part of oh
yeah it kind of goes with the
history thank you very much for having
yeah it's
perfect so for the record my name is
Karen Irwin and I am representing myself
today and I worked with David luno on
this particular bill because it I'm one
of the me and my husband are both one of
the people captured in this shortfall we
retired before July 1 2023 but we're as
of the last bill this fiscal note
doesn't address the number of people
that are encapsulated in this um fiscal
note but the prior year when it was put
in it was 3,000 individuals this won't
be effective for another year so I
figured that number would go down
because it's a finite group of people
it's only till you reach your um they
down in people it's only until you reach
your so full Social Security age so
um so anyhow what happened um was for
many years we' been putting in this bill
to eliminate the 10% because it has been
a disparity for I want to say close to
20 years you know prior to a couple
years ago and when um the fiscal note
was done by uh the retirement system
they defined members as active members
not retire re members even though the
language seemed to support it was for
retirees and um and so when that was
done that left out a whole bunch of
people that had retired prior to that
date July 1st and had not reached a full
retirement age So I myself will be
turning 65 this year and I would get the
decrease without this happening so I'll
get the decrease as well 3,000 other
people as of last year um
if you go to um page three I tried to
illustrate that this is a a closed end
situation because a good share of us are
at anybody 1960 and um a birthday is
1960 up to like you know after that is
67 is full Social Security retirement
age that was always the situation that
was supposed to be when you get full
retirement social sec security you get a
dip in your pension so that equated it
for most people anybody that retired
after that um they will not have that
dip at
65 um so as I put out you know it looks
like to me in 1962 if your birthday was
1962 you would get because of the cut
off of the fiscal year you get one month
of benefit in 20 30 and
so the fiscal note is written in a
certain way that it it says they um
based on the provisions of the bill will
be amortized over a a 20-year period and
that the costs involved will go well
beyond uh fiscal year 2028 and it really
wouldn't because of the age thing and
you know how people would retire and so
I'm not sure what they're speaking of
but um anyhow rais some questions
because the year before fiscal note
which I've also included for your
information is showed in um 26 and 27
520,000
um in those two years with a fiscal
acred liability of
11.1 you know our pensions going to go
down by 10% it's just being delayed by
two
years people like myself who have 36
years um in the system um I'm still we
have a 7% goes into an account that's
ours and I'm still drawing down that
account every payment that gets made is
drawn down from first from the employees
7% it is a if I passed away it is an
amount that would go to my kids
not the pension just the amount that's
in that
7%
so so that would definitely delay any
impact regarding you know that would
stretch it out till that money is all
run down and most all of us would be
within that five to six years and it'd
be all
relative so in my case if I needed to um
retire if because my pensions going down
by 10% if I needed that
you know absolutely had to live and
needed that uh
$469 in this case um and I had to take
my Social Security early that would be a
decrease in my Social Security of
another
$377 so I would lose
permanently because of those reasons I
would lose
$846 per month because of having to take
my Social Security early because my
pension went down early
so um we have a quite robust um you know
retirement system the returns have been
good even in you know the end of June it
was an
8.8%
return
um you know we we did uh the UN unfunded
liability for everybody else was 45
million and that went into the
retirement system and even if we could
somehow use some of that money that
would be helpful to cover the costs
because this is so ended it could be
really done almost in fiscal years not
you know drawing out on this acute
liability situation because it
everybody's going to reach 67 you know
or so if you're the only people that
would otherwise be captured or a little
bit of people in 1958 and people born in
1959 that retired before July 1st 202
23 um 10% of a pension is a lot for
um the uh they always look um at these
calculations as what is the
assumed interest rate uh which has been
6.75 for years and that was encompassed
in the previous fiscal note and they
earned 8.8 in the um Retirement System
just last year so if it could be used
that would be a funding source if that
could be used the you know the
percentage that gained over what
was deposited anyhow I uh respectfully
request that the executive department um
and administration approves this small
investment that doesn't significantly
detract from the public or private
sector uh it is a relatively small
amount of money the fiscal note reflects
its 13 million where last year it was
11.1 for the acred liability I'm still
not getting the expenditure
relationship for dragging it out for 20
years for um something that ends in
probably um I would think would end
in in State fiscal year
um I would estimate that it would be
very few people so I'm not sure how in
2028 when most of the people will be
have reached full retirement you know
most of the people in 1960 will have
reached full
retirement and if they retired before
July 1 2023 that's pretty early
retirement so I hope you look at the
policy of this and approve this forward
to finance and let them figure out the
numbers but um I appreciate your time
and I would welcome any questions all
right thank you are there any
questions vers GL um thank you madam
chair and thank you for being here um
you mentioned that in I'm still
relatively new to this area you
mentioned the individual account is
there a specifically earmarked
individual account that then goes to
your heirs yes and then the impact of
that I guess I'll ask the the the the
retirement about the impact if we were
to take it directly from there um S no
no it the that account does not directly
go to her heirs it is first used to pay
the pension okay and if there's if she
is so unfortunate it's to die before she
uses it up then then it would go to my
ears correct but the expectation is that
you will live long enough to empty that
completely out yeah yeah it takes five
or six years to empty it out in my
particular case it was 304 thou
um, and I just pointing that out that
you know we'd be using that a little
faster but it still kicks the ball down
the field a little bit you know
regarding the um unfunded liability is
what I was trying to point out so thank
you when I was listening I misunderstood
what you were saying so I appreciate the
clarity yeah okay any other
questions all right thank you very much
thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
637 yes I think the retirement system
issue well our point of view is we're
neutral you look like you just got asked
to the principal's office yeah well well
um I I think that there are a lot of
people who don't quite understand this
aspect of the law right so maybe I'll
speak first to the members
account so member
contributions are put in account in the
member's
name they are uh allocated interest once
a
year um based on the
2% less than the actual rate of no of
the assumed rate of return or the actual
rate of return so it can range from zero
to
4.75% that member account builds up at
any time the member terminates service
without taking a pension they can
request for that account to be
distributed to them or rolled over to a
401K with the
interest once a member
retires we then calculate their pension
and split it into two portions the
member annuity and the state annuity the
member annuity is the amount of the
benefit that can be funded with the
member's contribution
account and the state annuity
is a remainder of the annuity that's
paid from the state accumulation fund
which is made up of employer
contributions and investment
earnings uh to the extent the investment
earnings hav't been used to pay interest
to the member accounts um on
average that's about a 50 50 split there
are outliers depending on how your
career went someone went out on
disability work related disability in
the first month of working then 95% of
their benefits going to be funded by the
state fund because they've only made
contributions for a month so you know
there are outliers but on average that's
50% so when a member
retires um we start paying their
pension and we reduce dollar for dooll
their member account by the amount of
the pension so uh that gets
reduced if they were to pass away
without leaving a Survivor beneficiary
and there was still money in that
account it would go to a name
beneficiary as the prior speaker said it
was like five years it's it's somewhere
between five and seven years to
um uh to exhaust a member's account
there is a alternative benefit you could
pick where your current benefit would be
a little bit less but it would stretch
out that time that the member account
would be exhausted um some people opt
for that because of their own personal
circumstances and life
expectancies um but most people just
it's dollar for dollar so after about
six seven eight years your membership
count is gone and then your benefit is
funded through the state annuity from
that point on the state annuity
accumulation fund from that point on as
well as any Survivor benefit that you
may have left for a spouse or or or or
another person so that's how the member
account works this not like a 401k
account hey it's my money and I invest
it and then I take it when I want after
I uh terminate employment it's it's
there and it's your money and you always
get it for instance we have several
Provisions in our statute where we
offset a pension for workers comp for uh
excess earnings by someone who's on
disability for a retiree who exceeds the
uh limit on
ours those offsets are limited to the
state portion of their annuity we never
offset or cut back the member portion of
the annuity funded by their account
because that was their
money um so it is distinct in that
respect but once you
retire kind of loses that separateness
because the money is actually taken from
your account and paid over to the state
annuity accumulation fund at that point
and you maintain this book entry as you
wind it down just in case you were to
pass away before it was exhausted
there'd be some residual amounts
distributable to a
beneficiary um with that i' take any
questions on that
issue
y thank you madam chair and thank you
for explaining that I was wondering if
there was a way to do something like
that with this bill but I'm happy to
hear that there's already that that draw
down on the member account so thank you
for the clarity you're welcome any other
questions rep
scitech uh you said the member account
goes down I wasn't that to terminally
fund their retirement that it was I
thought the terminal funding of the
retirement would be in two pieces a
state piece and a member piece how does
a member member contrib uh account go
down well like I said the the member
account is transferred to the state
annuity accumulation fund and that's
what pays the pension however maintain
mainin a book
entry so that uh that reduces the
pension reduces the account by the
amount of your pension paid in the event
that you were to pass away prior to that
being fully exhausted because that was
your money whatever is remaining in that
account would be distributable to your
beneficiary so that you always get the
full benefit either in terms of in form
of an uh an annuity benefit or a refund
of accumulated or distribution of
accumulated contributions you always get
the full benefit of your member
interests thank you mother all right I
think settle that little all right
question nothing
further representative Leon has while
question thank you while you're here um
I just wanted to confirm that this would
entirely close um the the over s and we
wouldn't be coming back would we be
coming back in the future with a bill
like this for any other group of people
if we were to pass this I do not believe
so I think this just captures the people
who were in between the two old and new
benchmarks going forward there's just
going to be one Benchmark you're before
or after it so that was the intent thank
you um I have a question
would If This Were to pass and someone
had reached their full retirement age
and the pension was reset prior to its
effective date would they still would
they get a
change uh I can't answer that off the
top of my head but could you make a note
of
that U we can get an answer for you I I
I don't know I I did not participate in
drafting this bill or consult on it okay
yes I was wondering if it it was
not yeah okay thank you that's very
important your full retirement and
beened it go up you
questions thank you thank you very much
and is the uh fiscal note that we got is
in fact correct that it's
um what is it uh 7 700,000 and for the
uh yeah it's a fairly nominal amount
you does anyone else wish to testify on
all right in that case I'll close the
public
hearing
e
okay for the committee you've each
received a the latest copy of the
statutory Provisions for the retirement
system this is the 24 Edition which
replaces the 23 Edition that's in in in
the office
so it's a quick reference guide I trust
handy okay and it being
2:00 I'm opening the hearing on House
Bill 581 one I will mention that uh I am
questions I call the prime sponsor
representative
Maguire thank you madam chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is Dan Maguire I represent the town of
Epsom um our current uh State retirement
system is
Antiquated it's it's a form called
called a defined benefit pension plan
and that form of of retirement system
has essentially disappeared from the
private sector altogether and many
places in the public sector as well for
example UNH keen and
Plymouth roughly I think it's about 30
years ago uh switched from their defined
um benefit plan to a defined
contribution Pension Plan um and as a
result they have no debt no pension debt
um and from what I can I've talked to
the the chancellor about it and they're
very happy with with what they did on
the other hand the state has uh
something over5 billion doar including
Municipal but uh worth of pension debt
and you know it's it's theor Ally being
fixed over time but I'll talk about
there's been some some problems along
the way um I handed out an awful lot of
information and I'm I'm just going to
try to hit the highlights and not you
know go into too much detail until we
get to questions so let's talk about um
the main difference between a defined
benefit plan and a defined contribution
plan Define contribution plan is really
really simple it's it's a savings
account that's that's it so when when uh
money goes into that account as someone
is working some of the money just like
the other plans some comes from the
employer some come from the employee it
goes into a savings account the account
is invested it earns money taxfree and
then later when the person retires they
can withdraw money from their account a
Define Benefit Plan um similarly gets
money from the employer and the employee
but it promises the
employee uh a certain fixed payment
based on a on a formula and um so if
they work X number of years um X and and
their their um final compensation goes
into the equation and that creates a
number and they would be paid that that
amount for the rest of their life the
problem is um the the defined benefit
plan the kind we have now
is is poor in the presence of
inflation right um I'm working on the
budget right now we're using 2019 as a
as kind of a base to of comparison sort
of preco and in the six years since 2019
there's been 25%
inflation right so um plus 4% population
growth in New Hampshire so um so can you
can imagine if you're getting 25% in
inflation over 6 years what's it going
to be over the 20 plus years that
somebody has retired right so the you
know the value of their pension is going
down and down over time
whereas um a defined contribution plan
that has savings those savings can be in
assets that that increase uh with
inflation mostly typically stocks or
real estate things like that so it it's
better position to to keep up with
inflation secondly um the current kind
plan we have has 10year vesting so
someone has to work for 10 years um
before they're eligible to receive the
pension and many many do not we'll get
into exactly how many in a moment but um
whereas a defined contribution plan is
immediately vested there's no vesting
it's a savings account
and therefore it's completely portable
so if someone works for a short period
of time uh one year two years Etc they
get to keep that that amount and um it's
portable to their future future
employers
um I I for example my first job was for
the University of
California um in the late 80s and uh
they were preed enough to have a defined
contribution plan plan so I only work
for them for four years but I still have
the savings that you know have grown
over the succeeding what 40 years I
guess they're close to a 30 30 something
years all right um again the so this uh
a defined benefit plan the benefits end
when the retiree passes
away um or sometimes that or you can set
it up so the retire your spouse right um
but but it's not inheritable so if the
person dies young the benefits they
earned go back into the plan right
whereas again a savings account is their
own money it can be inherited by the
person's erors if the person passes away
uh unfortunately too young it's their
money right goes to their HS um all
right so the other thing that's not
maybe readily uh apparent is that a
defined benefit plan works essentially
by by guesswork there's there's which
you hire expensive actuaries to tell you
what's going to happen in the future and
you save as much as you need now to sort
of reach your
goal then and the problem is predicting
the future is extremely difficult and
I'll I'll show you the more detail in a
moment but whereas um a defined
contribution plan because it's a savings
account because it it works the way the
money actually um earns so so it's
obvious to the person who's saving that
they want to put in as much as possible
as as early as possible they want to
save when they're young right whereas
the key if you're in a defined benefit
plan the key to getting a good a better
retirement is what you earn at the end
not what you've saved at the beginning
right but what's actually in the plan is
based on what you saved at the beginning
so so a Define um contribution plan
matches reality in a better way if you
if you see what I mean I I can answer
questions about that all right so and
then what is the advantage for the state
so so this for the state um it a defined
uh contribution plan makes it so that we
cannot get into debt right it's a
savings plan we put in money as the
employee is working that's the end of
the state's obligation right whereas a
Define Benefit Plan um we have we can
get into debt because those guesses as
to what's going to happen in the future
can be wrong as they have been and and
um therefore future taxpayers have to
pay the expenses of today's
employees and that's simply wrong right
today's taxpayers should pay the
expenses of today's employees so uh it
avoids debt and debt is a killer as
we're going to you know probably find
out at the federal level sometime not
too long from now all right let's talk
about the bill so what the bill does do
is a very very small step for a very
small number of employees to just get us
started on on a defined contribution
system so first of all it only affects
group one employees who are state
employees it has nothing to do with
Municipal Employees it doesn't affect
Police and Fire group two employees it's
just group one state employees and it
only affects new ones ones who were not
yet hired right so the ones who will be
hired from when the bill passes assuming
it's July 1st from that point forward
well guess what we're probably in a
hiring freeze now because we're very
short of money so this is going to
affect very very few people until you
know as time goes on so so it's it's a
very slow growing small step type of
thing um the costs of the of the plan
are the same as as group one now from
the the employees point of view both in
group one now and in this plan the
employee puts in 7% of their salary um
the the bill uh as written we had the
very similar bill here two years ago and
so what's in this bill is the same as
this committee uh came up with in their
subcommittee process so that has sets
the employer rate at
5% that's something you can think about
and change if you if you felt like it um
it's I believe that's a little bit
higher than what the the state is
currently paying on on group one um
plans but it's it's more in line with
what you see in the private sector in
the private sector frequently there's
there's kind of a match between the
employer puts in X and the employee puts
in the same right that kind of thing so
okay um the the plan is set up to be run
exactly by the same board as our current
Deferred Compensation Plan that's known
as a 457 plan we have a the state has a
plan where employees can put extra money
into savings tax deferred very similar
to an IRA um and that plan currently has
about a billion dollars in it um and it
had one employee who just recently
retired so they're looking for somebody
to replace but but that's how simple
that plan is it's it's really doesn't
have much
overhead um and then the unfunded
liability uh associated with the current
plan um would still be charged to the
employer to this employer to the state
for these employees so so these
employees which we're going to call
group three would count as um as part of
the unfunded liability calculation so
this doesn't change that at all um
whether they're group one or group three
they would still be part of of payments
for the unfunded liability all right and
so that's the basics um I'll if you turn
the page here I already talked about
inflation a bit um so this plan are
we're having trouble hiring because the
defined benefit plan is very
unattractive to today's
employees and there's two ways of
looking at it one is this first section
here number of jobs held in a lifetime
so according to the um uh Bureau of
Labor
Statistics um the average person uh born
in 57 through 64 that's kind of my age
um has 12.7
jobs by the time they're 56 that's the
average right so some of them are having
20 jobs or 24 jobs or something crazy
like that right they're not they're not
sticking to a single job which is where
a defined benefit plan would would have
some some Merit right so they're they're
typically uh you know we're talking
about they stay in a job for a few years
and then they switch so portability is a
big thing for today's employees and then
the similar thing if you if you go down
there very few people in this group so
we're talking about regular state
employees group one state employees um
very few of them Reach the 10-year uh
Mark right so very few of them get
vested in the current plan so that means
they're giving up on benefits that they
have earned for themselves because
they're not staying for 10 years and I
had what I had in the back of my mind
that it was maybe 50% but the actual
numbers from the New Hampshire
retirement system that I got is much
much uh lower than that so so even after
just five years um 61% are gone of the
people that are H you know 61% of
employees who are hired last less than
five years um and and if you go forward
with these calculations it's something
like just over a quarter around
30% who reach 10 years right so so so
this plan that we have now doesn't work
for 70% of these employees so it's no
wonder we have trouble hiring right so
okay um I think I will oh and I wanted
to say something about um the ability of
the retirement system to to predict the
last page here you see this page that
looks like a giant spreadsheet right
that has big list of numbers so at the
time that the leg ISL finally figured
out that the retirement system had a had
a debt problem was around 2008 here and
uh that's when we got on the 30-year
plan to to fix it right and so this is a
piece of paper they got from the
retirement system that said if you
follow our plan you will pay off your
unfunded
liability uh by this uh 2039 right in 30
years and so look at the ability to
predict right if we go down this table
to 2025 today this table said they
predicted back then that our current
unfunded liability right now would be
3.125 billion well guess what it's
5.3 five 5.2 billion I think is what the
latest number is so it's two billion
more than than what was predicted then
so the the ability just because
somebody's an actuary and they're
probably the best best at predicting
doesn't mean they necessarily get stuff
right and so um that's the problem with
with the current kind of plan so um I
think
that's that should be enough and I'm
happy to answer
questions represent
BR thank
you I thank you for your passion on this
subject um but my understanding is that
one of the reasons why we have
trouble having people come to New
Hampshire is that they've lost trust in
the pension system because it's
continuously monkeyed around with in
legislation so how is it that this plan
won't have the same problem yes thank
you for the
question I think it's because again this
plan is a simple savings plan it doesn't
have features in the same way it doesn't
have I mean clearly the the the
legislature could decide well instead of
7% the employes should put in 8% or
should put in you know those kind of
things but but it's not um the number of
years to get to a to get to a pension
the multiplier of the pension what's
considered part of income and not part
of in all those kind of things that
people play with in the current plan
really aren't a problem in in this kind
of plan and and if they are they don't
affect the past you see what I mean cuz
cuz what we do sometimes when we make a
change we're making a change to the
whole system and it includes changing
what the expectations were from the day
somebody started until to until now you
see what I mean whereas in a savings
plan everything that happened from when
the day somebody started until now is
still there it's still there in savings
so even if you make a change somehow to
what's going forward it doesn't affect
the past and so it's the early Savings
in a pension plan that really make the
bulk of the of somebody's
pension representative sers yeah thank
you madam chair um most 401ks an an
example are vested I mean so they they
work for two three four years five years
and then they're 100 p 100% fested are
you saying at this point the the money
the state puts in at 5% is going to be
their money from day one if they retired
or quit yes thank you for the question
we could have put a one-year vesting or
something like that but the way the
Bill's written it's it's essentially
immediately vested so um if somebody is
only works for six months they get six
months worth of that that money I it
just seems simpler to us you guys could
certainly change that you know
representative long um so I take your
point about it being harder turn on your
microphone so I I see your point about
it being harder to hire younger
employees uh because of the current
system but uh since a defined
contribution system would primarily be
beneficial to younger employes I guess
would it be harder than to hire uh mid
or later career employees who don't get
as much of a benefit from uh having uh
returns acrew for as long a time on
their
contribution all right thank you for
that question but I I actually think
it's it's the other way around I know a
lot of people who have um joined State
service toward the end of their careers
right um and so only don't get to 10
years friend of mine is about to retire
after eight years right so
so the benefits she's earned over that
eight years toward the end of her career
is is essentially lost I mean they get
they get back their own contribution and
they get back a little bit from the
state contribution but they don't get
exactly what that would have earned over
that period of time if you see what I
mean so somebody who comes into State
service later in life probably already
has a 401k an IRA whatever and so this
would would accumulate or add to it if
you see what I
mean Howard uh thank you for taking my
question I know that you mentioned uh
portability and uh how many jobs the
average American Works uh over over
their lifetime I was just wondering if
you had more statistics on how that
related to New Hampshire uh like
preferably our state employee turnover
rate per se yes thank you for the
question the the best I have is on that
page um the the paragraph that says
starts with the nhrs actuaries assume
the following so it tells you that um
only
73% last a year of people that we hire
in this group uh the next year another
you know 21% leave the next year another
15% leave like that right so those are
the numbers that I got I did not get
these recently by the way I got these
from Mr Carlin before he retired two
years ago so they may not be 100%
accurate but but I'm sure they're
different long is there any data
available on as what the attrition rate
of state employees would be uh if there
wasn't this 10year vesting
requirement uh specifically I'm
wondering if people choose to stay
longer because of that
requirement yeah that's a good
question obviously not many are staying
that much longer right I mean if we're
only getting leaving 27% are getting to
10 years so so I it can't be a very big
um thing
I'm I but I don't know of any particular
studies or something like
that other questions so Madam chair I I
handed out two other things that I
should I should mention one is um
testimony from representative Wier about
his own experience he had both a defined
contribution and a defined benefit plan
um and he can't be here today and the
other one is an
amendment um I heard from the Department
of administrative Services yesterday and
there's a section of the bill which is
essentially the last paragraph in the
bill so if you go to uh
um almost the last paragraph you go to
page four line
19 um so what administrative Services I
my intention with this bill was not to
change anything related to health right
we we have a health retiree Health uh
coverage and and I didn't want you know
I wanted it to be exactly the same as
what group one currently gets and so
that was the intention of this paragraph
that's on line 19 and apparently
according to the Department of
administrative Services it's not written
correctly and so that's what this
amendment is for it's to fix it so that
um retiree health is the same for group
one and and group three and um it's much
more it's long but it's much more
understandable because basically in the
retire Health language it takes every
place where it says group one and says
group one or group three right so so
they would both be the
same all right thank you very much
excuse me we have another question
Howard yeah sorry about that thank you
so much for taking my question uh you
brought up a point that that kind of
sparked something uh so something that
you mentioned here on your uh your sheet
uh and handout it says that it only
affects new group one employees uh so I
understand that we're if we're not
trying to combine groups one and two uh
why are we going for group three here
just
to you mean why is it called group three
or because there will be I if I
understand your question it's because
there are existing group one employees
who will stay in group one right so and
plus there's a lot of Municipal
Employees who this doesn't cover right
so this is just about state employees so
right now in the retirement system um
20% of the of the members are state
employees and 80% are municipal and and
School Employees right so this is not
about that set this is about only the
the state employees and again only the
ones who will be hired in the future so
we tried to make this I mean this is
kind of a big change right I mean it's a
it's a big thing and and we so we wanted
to start you know this big right so so
this is as small a group as I can think
of and it's the group that would most
benefit from
this okay thank you other
questions thank you thank you madam
so good afternoon for the record again
I'm Mark Kavanaugh Deputy counsel in
compliance officer from New Hampshire
retirement system and here with me is
Diana kryon another attorney in our
department who's helping me fill in for
Marty and she's there to poke me in the
side when I say something
wrong but hopefully that will be
never
um we just yesterday received the report
from
GRS and so the fiscal note was not
prepared but we did put together a bill
brief
I distributed earlier that contains uh
essentially what we would put in the
fiscal not worksheet that will be
sending to LBA
tomorrow um I just wanted to ask whether
you wanted to talk about the legal
considerations or the financial
considerations first and let me premise
any of my comments by saying that we
this is a policy issue whether it's a
good idea to have a DC plan or not and
uh NH HR is neutral on that policy
decision but we are here to explain
potential Financial impact and to point
out a few technical uh and
administrative issues that
we see in the current bill unless there
are specific questions it looks to me
like the legal issues are
mostly unclear or uh Lang unclear
language or places where we need to
specify are there any questions
representative Pearson I have a question
for you your board of directors two
years ago and this similar bill came in
a policy position that rejected this
bill and did something that the
retirement system generally never does
and came out in opposition to that
legislation has that board reviewed this
uh no it has not but uh that was a
different piece of legislation so not
okay not by much but okay is the board
going to review this to make a
determination whether they want to set a
position or not the legislative
committee is meeting shortly and that
would be something that they consider
okay thank you so as I said unless
there's any specific questions about the
langu language details we'll leave that
for the
subcommittee um okay and then you can
give give the the whole committee the uh
the dollar
issues all right so under Financial
considerations and this is where the
cost enters into it it's in the the
upper table you see the projected
increase in employer
contributions in other words the 5% that
the employer would be paying plus the UA
that the employer would be paying the
employer the the employer being the
state uh with respect to group one
members who become eligible in the plan
that is those hired after 71
um the
lower table shows the savings by the
employer not making contributions
to NH HRS for these
employees as active
members and you'll notice there's a
difference uh in 2026 3.3 million versus
1.6 million it's one and then in uh 2027
6.2 versus
3 and fiscal year 28 8.8 versus
4.3 and you say what why why why is that
different well under the new plan the
employer will be paying
5% plus the
UA the state will for these people under
the existing plan the employer pays the
employer share of the normal cost which
is
2.4% plus the
UA so the new plan would
require employers to pay more because
it's nonua portion of its contribution
is the
5% whereas the nonua portion of
contributions to nhrs is for the normal
cost of 2.42 so that's why you see that
difference and and it it would grow year
after year as the um group three members
um that is it financially um there's a
couple other uh issues that would come
up due to the fact that the group one
state employees would become a closed
group uh no longer
expanding and so that would have two
results that at some point you would
have to alter your
investment strategy with respect to at
least these folks uh which would require
isolating group one state employees from
other group one employees and currently
actu it's all group ones are all group
ones and
that um as you get a group that's older
and older and closer to retirement and
they're not being replaced by younger
new hires you have a more urgent
liquidity needs to pay those benefits
which means you have to start investing
in things that have shorter
Horizons and um perhaps lesser returns
because they're more secure because
you've got to meet short-term known
obligations to pay pensions for this
group
um also at some point you would change
your contribution calculations from a
level dollar from a level percentage to
a level dollar um method and that can be
more expensive um a
level um dollar method is like a
mortgage you borrow
$360,000 for 30 years you pay the bank
back ,000 a year a month or plus
interest and so you got a fixed payment
it's it's level
dollar level
percentage is a level percentage of
compensation taken into account
Actuarial uh predictions as to payroll
growth and inflation and the like level
percentage um is used by
70% of of plans level dollar is used by
about 30 % of plans um it was decided
when we uh put our plan into place to uh
address the
underfunding uh to use a level
percentage because it has a lesser cost
that spread over time whereas a level
dollar would have had a much
higher um percentage but as you've got a
fixed group of
people and you don't have new employees
coming in that you can predict payroll
there is no payroll growth other than
increases in individual members salary
you don't have payroll growth from new
hires expansions of the
workforce um and and therefore you don't
have the ability or it's less accurate
to use a level percentage as the measure
so these are two things our actuar has
point out is a
possibility um but they couldn't put an
exact dollar and cents on it but we
should be aware that those are some of
the long-term risks of having a closed
group that eventually everyone's going
to retire from and and when the last
person retires you're getting normal
contributions for that person so you
better have everything you need to pay
for everyone who's retired for the rest
of their lives um one other point I
wanted to make in the actuary uh points
out in his report which we'll be
providing to LBA tomorrow is um the fact
that
we evaluate uh
un the unfunded acred liability
by
group uh or by member
class employees teachers police fire we
have two groups teacher
and uh employees are in group one police
and fire are in group
two groups that are deline ated by job
type group three would be a delineation
by a higher date a completely different
Paradigm to call someone group three we
have always measured the liability for
group ones between the state and the
political
subdivisions uh
employees as one
group now if you go forward um it is
possible and you're still measuring
things as one group as a and there's
been no dictat in this statute or others
for us to change that method
um it could result in the state actually
subsidizing the costs of political
subdivisions but through that
UA
component um that's an actual concept
that's just a little bit above my
comprehension I've been a pension lawyer
for 32 years and I have a fair knowledge
of actual M matters this is a
particularly subtle thing that the but
it would require according to our
actuary that uh in order to accurately
reflect what those uh that what that UA
should be for state
employees um who remain in the system
or go to the new plan based on their
higher date
whether that should be separate
separated out and calculated
differently than for regular group one
employees of political
subdivisions um so it it's unclear the
language is ambiguous and it doesn't use
the word UA but we assume that's what
they meant it uses some other
terminology that doesn't exist but we
assume what they mean is the
UA and I think that's a fair assumption
um but a question
you you have an unfunded amount and you
calculate what the contribution
percentage would be by taking that
unfunded amount and dividing it by the
compensation of the members involved
well this statute is ambiguous about
whether it means the members that remain
with nhrs or do we somehow count the
compensation of the members who have now
moved over to the DC plan obviously the
first would create a higher contribution
percentage because you're you're taking
that unfunded liability and spreading it
over a smaller group a static group um
but the mechanics of bringing in the
contribution and the compensation
amounts from the the the uh group three
or the DC plan
members um make make that doubly
complicated I think it needs to be
clarified what is intended to mean by
what the state would be paying on behalf
of um DC plan members towards the UA in
any particular uh details that that
would require to make it clear what our
charge was um so that's basically the
financial side of it I would be glad to
answer any
questions thank you repr Pearson thank
you madam chair you have covered a
plethora of reasons why this this
is a dumpster fire um uh not my words
those are my words I was just facts not
a point of view or we're going to get to
some facts because I got to be careful
because the one time I expressed an
opinion in this place I got raked over
the calls I was here when you diding an
opinion yep I was here when you did that
so you
mentioned when the dollar amount runs
out right because you said
said
um that at some point right you're not
having contributory funds come
into group one right because everybody's
not paying in and you said when the
dollar amount runs out they're going to
need to have you better hope they have
enough money to pay the pensions if they
don't who's going to have to make up for
that missing money well the the the plan
assets are all one pool of assets
available to pay benefits for all
members and groups we separate the
groups for purposes of assessing
contributions and portions of the
UA to try to allocate those costs but in
the end all 12 billion dollars we have
is available to all members so if you
come up short you come to a particular
payroll we don't say here's how much
dollars we have available to pay for
group one members but actuar we're
looking at that group been
saying it's getting smaller and smaller
and eventually everyone's going to be
retired and so we should
actuar account for that
eventuality by adjusting rates now to
make sure we have money until the and to
the extent we those calculations you
know they're not infallible uh events in
the
world downturns in economies uh unfunded
legislation changes in
Actuarial assumptions uh can all affect
what the underfunding is but that would
all be reflected in the contribution
rates and we would we wouldn't run out
of money and the there would be money to
pay but on paper you would say that's
not enough so we got to start charging
more to make up for that um so that's
what I meant to say okay to the math on
that follow up um is I'm trying to
remember currently right now it is it
not something like
85% of the money coming in from payroll
dispersement uh maybe I said that
backwards the dispersements cover 85% of
the dispersement that's currently
happening is that not coming out of
direct payroll and then the other 15%
comes from um Investments and
I think yeah approximately current
contributions cover approximately around
80 85% of current
benefits so we you know the
contributions paid in a particular year
don't cover all the benefits paid in
that year and it's always been that way
that's why you have investment earnings
sure that you count on I can't
underestimate the importance of
investment earnings in this equation it
it's never if if if annual contributions
equal annual
distributions you wouldn't need to
invest anything sure you know but in a
perfect world that's not the way it
works so follow up to that then if the
amount of contributions continues to
decrease as people are being removed out
of that into this into group three is
that going to then Force the either the
Investments are going to have to perform
better or you're going to have to find a
way to have the paycheck contribution
percentage change or get larger to cover
theoretically the the the contribution
rates would have to accommodate the fact
that this fixed pool of group one state
employees is not
growing and uh that that and such that
you you can't predict uh or rather you
can predict that your future
contributions with respect to that
cohort are going to be less and to the
extent you're you you you're determining
how to pay current benefits through
current contribution revenues or through
Investments then the actuar is making
adjustments to say that's an imbalance
we need to charge more or the UA would
increase and we need to charge more for
employer contributions in order to make
up that
difference but that's I mean these
things are all inherent in a plan that
frees is all or a portion of its
membership to Future participation that
the plan is now going to age out
prematurely than it would over normal
cost and lifespan of of a pension plan
because you have put a a drop dead date
that says no new members after that time
and that that um that throws a monkey
wrench in the actuary's
normal calculations that there will be
payroll growth through inflation payroll
growth through expanded
employment and um you know in some cases
for instance with teachers we reduced
our payroll growth because there were
fewer teachers so we had an actual
assumption in the last valuation think
we reduced it from 2.5 to 2.1 because
the reality of the world is there aren't
going to be as many teachers and once
you re reduce that as one of your actu
factors in in in assumptions that's
going to have a down the road effect on
on calculating how much money you're
going to be able to collect to to uh
towards the U portion of the employer
contribution and and adjustments are
made in that amount
accordingly thank you representative
sellers thank you madam
chair is isn't group three the new group
still going to be paying in to the what
do you call it UA the the employers will
be now I will say in my technical
section and if we're having a
subcommittee that' be the time to talk
about that doesn't say how that's
supposed to happen but
presumably the employers will have a way
of tracking this is how much
compensation that we paid our 5% on and
here's your UA portion on that same
compensation another technical issue is
what is compensation our plan is
different than that plan but those are
technical issues I think can be worked
out
it can be worked out yes yes other
questions representative long uh
currently what is the annualized return
on uh the Retirement Systems Investments
over say the last 10 years and do you
have a sense of what it would have to be
in order to uh remain liquid uh if you
were not getting more new well our
actuaries do their basic C calculation
based on an assumed rate of return of
6.75% and so when they're calculating
whenever they're calculating a
liability the present value of liability
for future pensions or the present value
of future contributions or expected
earnings they're using 6.5 as the 75 as
the discount rate and the actual 10%
return was in the presentation yeah and
the presentation last time we we gave uh
351 uh in 20 years and uh I believe all
of those were over the
6.75 the 20 year is the best because it
encompasses some years more than 20
years ago and the markets when were more
robust but we have uh consistently
exceeded our past fiscal year was 8
point
something um and so our investment
performance is has been above the
assumed rate of return
and uh and been very favorable in comp
in comparison to our peer
plans thank you representative cyc oh
excuse me represent long you have
another followup uh yeah so the second
half of my question was do you have any
projections on what the returns would be
if you were having to if I could I
wouldn't be working here I'd be playing
I mean no who can predict right who
would have predicted Nvidia would
increase in value tenfold over two years
and who would predict it would then
crash by 40% in a
day you know the world is wall Street's
full of people who pretend they can
predict but uh I'm not one of
those repr
scitech Mr Kavanaugh you've painted a
pretty Grim picture of what happens with
this closed group isn't this all due to
the fact that we have a
UA that in fact it doesn't matter
whether the group is open closed up or
down if there's enough assets to cover
when the last person retires there's
that last bit of investment that will
cover him right to the end is that are
we not paying that price of the UA and
being unable to fund the Clos group from
all the well I would say for the most
part that's accurate statement in a
sense that if there was no U there would
be less um economic concerns about
having a closed group you'd still have
the issue of investment Horizons and
liquidity that now you've got to invest
in safe liquid Investments and maybe
you're R to return is only going to be
3% uh instead of six or 6.75
uh and and so there are both set of
factors but yeah if we had no
UA we we'd all be very happy but it's
something all of us on both sides of
this table inherited uh 20 years ago
almost and or 20 plus years ago and
we're doing our best to to work our way
through it over the long-term plan well
I just can't help this are the the
member are the employees of the New
Hampshire Retirement System in the
retirement system oh
wonder I I I just wanted to point out
one thing that representative McGuire
said about late in life employers
employees not working the 10 years we do
have vesting by age if you reach age 65
you can retire if you got three years of
service so I mean you can get a pension
you're not leaving the state's portion
on the table you can take your money and
leave it but you could apply for a
pension albe it a small one but there is
age vesting not everyone has to have 10
years thank you other questions I have a
question about uh some Language online
in page
one so at the bottom on 27 28 and 29 it
talks about determining
positions that transition over I'm sub
um paraphrasing
but so a person that works at
a job leaves and they hire a new person
right so now they're subject to this
group three they were subject to group
one and it's saying that the UA for that
position will
continue right right you're going to pay
that I filed a bill two years ago to
prevent political
subdivisions from declassifying if I
it's probably the best word for it
declassifying positions to get out of
paying the
UA I think Marty handled it but one of
the things that came out of that was how
extremely difficult it would be to
determine which positions had a UA how
would you assign a number and then how
far back in the position existence do
you go those were things that were
expressed has any of that changed or
gotten better in two years um not
particularly I mean there's the the
unfunded liability is an aggregate
number
um and so it's difficult you know with
respect to a particular group or
position the only time where that
particular we've done it once uh when a
charter school wanted to
withdraw and in order to withdraw from
the system and no longer participate
they had to pay their share of the
unfunded and it was calculated based on
employees it had who were vested or
already receiving
benefits and and it was a substantial
they had three people and they had to
pay a substantial amount of money to get
out of the plan everyone else who's
asked since is just blocked at the
number so in in that circumstance where
you have fixed people you know where
they are what benefits they're invested
in what benefits they're C they're
collecting it is possible to say all
right our overall underfunding is uh 20%
we owe them
$1,000 So 20% $200 is your underfunded
allocated and you got to pay us those
$200 you want to get out of the system
but on an AG to say oh let me just look
at all uh
janitors well it's just you know the
demographics are all over from janitors
who just got hired to janitors who have
40 years of service you're not you're
not going to be able at a group level
ascribe that we we do do it by by uh um
member type you know employee teachers
you know those those are big picture
things and it is possible for the large
groups to say all right the UA here is a
little different than here because of
the overall average demographics of the
different groups and the benefit
structures and the like but if an
employer came and said I want to
eliminate positions a b c and d how much
am I going to save we'd say that's not
the way it works you'd have to change
the law first and I don't even know if
thank you other questions seeing none
all right thank you very much and I I
trust we'll be be able to have your help
at the
good afternoon Madam chairwoman
honorable members of Edna committee for
the record my name is Richard gulla I
president of the state employees
Association and I am honored to be
representing over 10,000 hardworking New
Hampshire public employees and
retirees we are the men and women who
plow our roads ensure we have clean
water to drink and our children are safe
and our elderly are cared for we are
your neighbors and friends we are
taxpayers we are dedicated public
servants who have helped build New
Hampshire and continue to keep New
Hampshire great thank you for allowing
me to provide comments and concerns
relating to HB 581 establishing a state
retirement plan group for new state
employee members of the retirement
system over the last 24 years New
Hampshire legislatures under both
Republican and Democrat control control
have said no to enacting legislation
relating to a defined contribution plan
C appendix a in your
handout there have been no new relevant
information brought forward to Warrant
this proposed change in the past the
numerous versions of the proposed Define
contribution plan included everyone in
groups one and two HB 581 is taking a
divide and conquer approach this year
just like in
2324 with h Bill 55 59 by excluding
teachers and firefighters and police
officers from the bill leaving state
employees to fight this on their own
regardless of the exclusion of some the
concept is still bad for New
Hampshire retention and recruitment our
state employee seems to be the buzzwords
in almost every conversation we are
hearing in the legislature over the past
few years supporters of this proposed
change have stated portability as a
quote unquote strength of a defined
contribution plan by saying quote
portable immediate vesting savings
maintain when changing
employers how is that doing anything to
promote retaining our employees it's
encouraging them to leave the state will
spend money on training these employees
only to have them leave not only what
they put into the Divine contribution
plan but what we the taxpayers put into
the plan as well currently and if
employee leaves the New Hampshire retire
system prior to being vested they can
only take the funds they contributed
with them they do not have the ability
to take taxpayers money that was
invested this legislation is bad for
taxpayers you may hear that a defined
contribution plan is what younger
Workforce desires because of its
portability well there's been a real
life recent unsolicited example that
proves the opposite during the years of
TW 2020 21 and 22 the community college
system of New Hampshire new hires were
given a choice between the two
retirement plans and they overwhelmingly
chose to join the New Hampshire
retirement system 73% of the 82 newly
hired full-time staff between 200 20 and
22 chose the New Hampshire retirement
system over ccsnh H's 403b plan when
given the choice 60 chose the retirement
system 22 chose the 403b
Define contribution 403b plans may be
appropriate for private sector employees
however HB 581 would force hardworking
New Hampshire state employees to take on
new long-term risks the newly hired
state employees under this bill would be
solely deal with the inflation risks
investment risks and the risk of
outliving the funds in a defin
contribution 403b plan there is a
tremendous responsibility involved in
managing one's own retirement plan not
everyone has the knowledge or exper
expertise of navigating various
investment strategies which would put
many if not most at a
disadvantage HB 581 would most certainly
create cost shifting back on the state
should retirees outlift the funds of
their defined contribution plan the New
York Stock Exchange was founded May 17th
1792 and in your handout below I'm not
going to read them all but you can see
the 10 worst days in the history of the
New York Stock Exchange typically
measured by the largest single day
declines in the Down Jones Industrial
Average imagine being a Hampshire state
employee relying solely on the defined
contribution plan as a result of this
bill in the almost 233e history of the
New York Stock Exchange 8 out of 10 or
80% of the 10 worst days in history Cur
in the last 16
years in addition to the worst 10 days
on record 10 of the worst years on
record and the 233 year history of the
New York Stock Exchange four of the top
10 worst years have occurred in the last
24 years according to Money Talks news
2001 2 8 and
22 state employees understand by working
for the State of New Hampshire they will
be compensated Less in the private
sector but they have a work work life
balance and are assured a defined
benefit for the rest of their lives in
addition to our current mandatory
defined benefit plan state employees can
enroll in the state's
voluntary defined contribution plan
457b should they want to save additional
money for retirement this has been in
existence since
1977 having the retirement security of a
Divine Benefit Plan and the optional 457
plan is a wonderful recruit roting to HB
581 removes the retirement security
currently offered by the state and a
much needed recruiting tool please join
both Republican and Democrat legislators
from over the last 24 years by
considering their numerous well-thought
out conclusions on this issue and
continue to reject the idea of a defined
contribution plan for our hardworking
state employees who are not asking for
this change thank you for your
consideration
thank you are there any questions
representative
slotty thank you madam chair um you
mentioned that uh the Dow Jones is
somewhat
volatile uh and is is somewhat of a
danger for investment uh it made me
curious as to where the defined benefit
plan funds are invested in the current
retirement
system I don't know the answer to that
question
it it is in fact in the handout on the
questions I have one if unless
representative scitec does okay um
have reports out of Alaska have
indicated that when they attempted to do
this they completely and totally lost
the ability to hire anybody have you had
any contact with a counterpart of yours
in Alaska to see if that's improved or
changed or are they still having the
same inability to hire B during this
type of plan I haven't had any direct
contact just what I've read and and they
are having difficulty and in fact
they're trying to reverse what they what
they did out there because it's costing
you other questions thank thank you very
thank you for this opportunity to speak
before you for the record again my name
is Karen Irwin and I live in the town of
hopkington
and I am a retired state
employee I just wanted to point out a
few things
um regarding this bill I'm in opposition
to
it um for more than 50 years the New
Hampshire State retirement system has
been playing an important role in the
state's public employees which include
teachers police officers and Fir
fighters in a Divine benefit plan the
current employees contribute 7% of their
gross pay and the state of New Hampshire
contributes
13.5 based on their year of salary and
service and 10 years is required for
vesting um except age is a
factor the amounts according to the last
48569 active members and 4
5,330 retiree beneficiary or
beneficiaries that is a lot of people to
be impacting with a new plan uh the
following
um the following is the concerns of the
bill I misunderstood the way the bill
was written that it would only be
affecting um state employees and it
would not be affecting firefighters
police and teachers into a very
different plan called the defined
contribution plan the plan is very
different than the defined benefit plan
in that and it the bill provides for the
fact that there's going to be a defined
contribution commission which doesn't
sound like that's going to be a part nor
can it be a part of the New Hampshire
retirement system so it is very
separate um they're going to you know
have the employees contribute 7% but the
employer will only be contributing
five um that's a big change and
until um representative Maguire
mentioned it I also and I'm not sure but
it clearly says that insurance won't be
covered I mean it'll be at their own
expense is what it says there now I
don't know with the amendment if that
corrects it or fixes it but um group
three Health in Insurance the way it's
stated here uh would be able to
participate only at his or her expense
we pay something but we don't pay the
whole cost of the um Insurance to today
I looked the rates up if I was to add a
dependent uh you would be paying
$1,444 cents a month for that dependent
if you had more than one you would be
paying it for two or three or whatever
but if you had only one dependent you
wanted to add to the retire health
insurance that's the kind of plan we
have so that could be the cost they
would have to participate in um that's
pretty significant clearly nobody could
cover
that um the acred liability contribution
percentage chargeable to a group three
employer shall be determined by charging
group one member ACR liability
contribution for group three members I
am not sure what that means but I'm not
sure how that but that's a concern
because I don't understand what that
language is trying to say
um the defined contribution Commission
shall be allowed to co-mingle or pull
assets with assets of other people or
entities um I don't know what that means
again and I don't think they can be
pulled with any nhrs
Investments um so um that sounds scary I
mean I know it was referred to as a
savings plan but it's going to operate
like a regular defined compens um we
have a deferred comp plan that we can
join join as well and it's an investment
so in Investments they try to monitor it
so you don't have a lot of losses but
you have winning and losing you're not
going to be just putting it into a money
market you know and so this isn't just a
savings plan they can walk away with
they're going to have whatever their
results are of their 7% plus five not 13
and a
half
um you know I recently retired as I've
said before with um after 36 years and
it's all relative putting 7% in I had
over
$34,000 in my account and the state was
contributing
13.5 so you can kind of do the math and
figure out how much is sort of
attributable you know it's not directly
attributable but just so you know how
much has been collected over the years
um from the employer and the employee
percentage because of all those unknowns
I do not think you know anybody is doing
a good F fiduciary
responsibility by separating this group
with all of these
unknowns and the portability on this you
know it's something you can leave the
state leave your money in the retirement
system and then it adds to your years
what's going to happen to all the people
that do that I did that I worked for the
state for seven years left for seven
came back left my money in the
retirement
system worked three more years and
became
vested um you don't want to take your
money out of the retirement system if
you have some years in it and
um you know it's a big difference
between a defined benefit plan and we
have a system that's working
well and it's going to continue to work
well and it's a great benefit for our
state employees and the you know
everybody says out in the Working World
I wish I had a pension I wish I did you
know and this is being done for
employees today and been doing it for 50
years so it's been
working um making this a close end fund
and making all liabilities it just
sounds like big I don't know but um I
definitely hope you join me in in
legislation thank you yeah are there any
questions no doesn't look like any thank
Moore good afternoon madam chair members
of the committee thank you for the
opportunity to speak here today for the
record my name is Greg Moore I am
Regional director with Americans for
Prosperity here today to testify in
support of House Bill
581 um give a little personal anecdotes
I know that the sponsor mentioned that
uh only 27% of people actually vest in
the program that's actually that's
actually uh a high number because there
are people like me who uh given a choice
did not choose to join the Hampshire
retirement system when I became a state
employee in 200 three so that that
doesn't count for the does not account
for the people who simply choose not to
participate in New Hampshire retirement
system so that numb actually high I
would tell you that that looking at uh
looking at the legislation uh it would
create a benefit that is meeting the
needs of our people younger people
joining the
workforce uh there was a time when this
program came into life where people were
looking for a job where they started and
they continued through their career and
then they and they left and that met the
needs of the workers back when this when
the retirement system was was begun
that's no longer the case there was a
much bhood study about a dozen years ago
about how Millennials change jobs every
18 months well a CNBC study said that
geners are changing jobs once every 15
months so that pace is actually
accelerating workers want jobs where
they can they can come they can work and
they can leave and they can take what
they've made and bring it with them I
also have one one point that I would
mention about the legislation that it
does not include and then and again
you'd have to look at the Actuarial
tables etc etc but what it doesn't
include is the opportunity for um
unvested workers to switch to this new
system and I will tell you I will tell
you with somebody and this was to
representative Long's point I had a
cooworker when I was at Health and Human
Services who literally had a countdown
clock as a screen saver it took me a
while to figure out what it was I had to
ask him and he told me and it started
out about 3 years when I left the
department it was down to a year he was
counting down the time until he hit his
10-year Mark and he could and he could
leave the state so because 10e unbroken
State service is an extent is a long
period of time for most pension systems
even to Define benefit ones and so I
would I would say to you that consider
the Pro Prospect of people who might
want to move from a the current defined
benefit system who are not yet vested
and to take take this opportunity to
switch into this system I don't think
any employ EMP should be trapped in a
job that they don't
like great it might mean retention but
I'll tell you that the employee that the
employee that was in question good good
guy not the most motivated employee as
I'm sure you can imagine so I I'd ask
you to consider that as you go through
your deliberations and through your
subcommittee with that I'd be happy to
take any
questions represent zitech how were you
able to not join the New Hampshire
retirement system I thought it was
obligatory so uh in my two stin with
State service I was an unclassified
employee in the first stint and in the
second stint I was working for the I was
employee
yes other
questions thank you very much thank
bodri thank
you Madam chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is arur
bodri I represent the New Hampshire
State permanent firefighters retirement
Association I am a retired captain from
the Manchester fire department and I
also was a member of the Board of
Trustees for the New Hampshire
retirement system for 13 years I'm here
to speak in opposition of House Bill
581 other than collecting the unfunded
acred liability associated with group
three employees there is very little if
any association or oversight by the New
Hampshire reti system the bill amends
RSA 100a by inserting group three
retirement system definition defined
contribution plan but when you read
under the administration rulemaking on
line 28 the New Hampshire retirement
system has virtually nothing to do with
administering the fund it states that
the administrator of the plan shall be
the executive director o of the Deferred
Compensation Plan who shall have an
assistant uh who shall have the
assistance and services of the
Department of administrative services
for the duties and responsibilities
under the subdivision not the New
Hampshire retirement system the
department of administrative Services
May employ or assign staff to the
executive director and commission for
the administration of the plan this bill
creates a whole new administrative
Department the New Hampshire retirement
system management and the Board of
Trustees will not be involved the
director shall adopt rules pursuant to
oursa
541a this has nothing to do with RSA
100a the New Hampshire retirement system
the commission made contact uh contract
with a thirdparty administrator for the
administration of assets accumulated
under this uh participant account so the
members contributions will not be part
of the New Hampshire retirement system
the New Hampshire retirement system
border of Trustees will have no say in
how these contributions will be invested
the commission will be in charge of
managing investing and administrating
the plan the contributions by the member
participating shall be 7% of earnable
compensation the plan and the employer
uh to the plan and the employer will
contribute 5% when ta TI AA C came
before the legislature in 2011 to
testify that a 30 to 35 year employment
at age 65 on Social Security the total
contribution rate should be 12% 6% for
the employer
and 6% for the employee this this is no
uh there is no language in this bill
that allows for accidental disability or
death this is also a topic that was
discussed uh with Tia cff they and they
had to look at pursuing purchasing life
insurance and disability insurance
benefits which cost would be over and
above the 12% of contribution rate that
went along with the 4 414h plan that was
off it at that
time by eliminating participation in the
New Hampshire retirement system this
will impact the unfunded ACR liability
without new contributions coming into
the system it will be very difficult to
maintain the current New Hampshire
retirement system as we know it we have
talked about Recruitment and retainment
of employees this is no way to go about
accomplishing that other states have
tried similar changes and ended up going
back to their original plans case study
of the state and pension plans that
switched to defined contribution plans
presented summaries of past changes in
three states Retirement Systems that
made their switch to the DC plan from a
traditional DB uh pension case studies
covering the following states West
Virginia Michigan and Alaska rather than
saving States money these DB to DC
switch exasperated the uh funding
problems and drove up pension debt
overall certain uh Trends appeared
common in all three states such as
changing from a DB plan to a DC plan did
not help the existing
underfunding uh problem and in fact
increased Pension Plan cost workers
under the DC plan face increased level
of retirement insecurity the best way to
address a pension underfunding problem
is to implement a responsible funding
policy by making the full and annual
requirement contribution each year and
to evaluate and adjust assumptions as
well as funding overall over time we
have read the entire CA if you want to
read the entire case study published on
the National Institute of retirement
security there has been a plan
established by the legislature to pay
off the unfunded acred liability in the
New Hampshire retirement system when
that is done the normal cost for state
employees is going to be
2.42% less than the 5% that's under this
bill
the system is not broken if the past
legislators would have left the system
alone we would not be in the condition
we are today it is due to past
manipulation of funds changes to the
assumptions and methodologies that help
create a major part of the problems we
are solving today let the New Hampshire
retirement system continue its course
it's Been instrumental to thousands of
members for over nearly 60 years please
vote the itl house bill 581 and I will
answer any questions thank you are there
questions represent s did you say those
three states switched back the three
states that they did a study on that
yeah uh it was yes uh West Virginia
Michigan and
Alaska that that was a study or they
actually switched
back they went to a DC plan I believe I
know Alaska did um the other two um I
believe did also but I'm not sure if
they left the Gap there but you can read
the whole study it's on the national
inst Institute on retirement security is
where that information is
available thank you other any questions
I have a question in reference you
mentioned something about
um uh death and disability in insurance
policies can can you can you just hit
that one more time yes uh when we went
when we went through the same exact
thing back in 2011 that was brought up
um there's nothing in the current
legislation that if you get injured in
the line of duty or if you die in the
line of duty there's no there's no
benefit all you get is your defined
benefit plan uh defined contribution
plan so if you're a new employee and you
only have $1,000 in that plan you you
die that that's all you're getting you
don't have you have no insurance so they
said that they when I say they um uh the
group that testified back then Tia cff
stated they would have to purchase
accidental disability and death benefits
to pay off those um those members MERS
follow up yes who would have to pay that
would for those policies that would be
part of the cost associated with
implementation of the plan so it' be
open and above the 12% that they were
saying was going to cost the to
implement the plan does that mean
employer is that what you're saying it
okay okay any other
you referenced this for Mo brief moment
in your testimony a moment ago but is it
not the case that uh that when the
legislature started tinkering with the
system back in I think about the 1990s
you hit it on the head
but uh that they were told by the
employees unions and so forth uh warned
not to do this uh this was going to uh
you know cause problems in the long run
and so forth uh that you were by
creating the special account and all
these other things and so forth you were
creating a Sit situation where
liabilities and assets were going to
cross at some
point uh and the system was going to go
underwater and we were
misinformed I wasn't in the legislature
at that point but it only seemed like it
um but in any case they they uh they
they were told not to do this oh it was
supposed to be a short-term solution
it's only going to be for short term
because they were going to help out the
employers by lowering
their the call on their assets uh to
keep it going but uh the the net effect
was it got forgotten that it was going
to be shortterm it got left in effect
and the the then
actuary told us we were 125% funded we
had plenty of monies and so forth uh and
ultimately when I came on Edna 19 years
ago we were confronting the reality that
we were in the ditch and going down fast
and we had to
undo uh the that that situation and
that's when we started dealing with the
UA right yeah you're absolutely correct
representative correct representative in
1990 they changed the interest
assumption rate up to 9 and three
quarters which was unprecedented at the
time was the highest rate of interest
assumption in the country um and they
changed the methodology from entry age
normal to open aggregate Group which
pushed the liabilities off to the Future
and they they never got paid off so that
you're absolutely correct that was the
key to the start of the downfall of the
system was when they started messing
around with the interest assumption
rates and the methodology and now they
finally turned it back to the old way
isn't it also the case that uh that
that's when they created the special
account special account was created in
1983 well it was back in that general
area but but given the the assurances of
the actuary that we were 125% funded you
know all all the the all the returns all
the earnings over I think it was 8 and
3/4% or something like that they flowed
over into the special account correct
anything over one anything over one half
or 1% of the assumed rate of return went
into the special account that's right so
that money was was taken out of the
Corpus so you never had a really good
year from that point on isn't that the
case we had good years until 2000 then
then when when the market crashed um it
was a Snowball Effect be because the
money was being siphoned off over and
above the assume rate of return When
good years when we had a bad year there
was no money going into the system to
make up that bad year so you never had
is it not the case you never had thank
you madam chair that you never had a
really good year you only had good years
and bad years because the the the really
good years the those revenues went into
the special account correct and to be
honest with you a representative with
that I was on the board when they made
those changes and I was one of two board
members that voted against all those
changes because we felt it was going to
hurt the system and when they wrote down
the assets uh and and to pay off the
Social Security offset for group one
that was a $200 million piece of
legislation that they took 20% of the
assets because they did say we were 135%
funded um and then once the benefit was
paid for they never paid for new
employees coming on that bill was
exponentially expensive and that's when
the rat started going up for the
employers and that's when they
complained back in 1990 cuz the that
bill went in in
1988 then they started changing the
methodology to try to catch up to what
the rates were going
up thank
you thank you that was a long
explanation I'm sorry madam chairman the
it's the history that you remember
because you were there and the rest of
us weren't thank you okay don't see any
blazel thank you madam chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Bob blazel I'm the senior lobbyist for
the state employees
Association I
um would like to just point out a couple
a couple things here um first and
foremost um representative scitec you
had a question
about of Mr B relating to which states
and whatnot if you look at the handout
that was given by Rich gulla earlier
it's all passed out in the back of his
written testimony you will see that
entire um you will see the entire study
right here which includes um all of
those states with a very detailed uh
message um that that message is is
basically um among the states that
switched to a DC Plan cost
Rose negative cash flow
grew and the employee turnover
increased um this is for Alaska Kentucky
Michigan Oklahoma and um West
Virginia
um it also talks about how it it leaves
taxpayers supporting the cost of two
plans uh for for many many
decades um it talks about how among the
states studied here uh previously
mentioned the employer cost increased
significantly uh after closing a pension
plan
um in the closed plans cash flows have
become more negative over
time um you know the available data
suggests that DC plans are are are
failing to help many workers accumulate
um efficient retirement
savings you know it goes on and on and
and this isn't any new information you
also have the legislative history um in
that same packet um it it's just we just
have more more upto-date current um
information about why this isn't good
for the taxpayer it's not good for uh
recruiting new employees um it's not
good for the backend for these group
three employees that um you heard about
the stock market you know how it it I
mean it's very very different to have to
have a defined benefit plan within the
Hampshire retirement system and kind of
struck me odd
the the sponsor of this Bill said and I
quote earlier today defined benef the
defined benefit works by guesswork and
expensive
actuaries I I that makes absolutely no
sense to me um this this legislature uh
put into place um an investment
committee over at the New Hampshire
retirement system with highly capable
individuals if you look at for the last
years okay the rate of return they
they're averaging
7.9% now whether that's guess work or
not that's that's pretty good in 2024
was 8.8 in 2023 was
8.2 pretty good guesswork no it's
actually not guesswork it's intelligent
people who take their roles
very it's this is something that is um
very important for our
retirees there is no guesswork I just
need to emphasize that it was also
stated that the amendment here uh came
out of the subcommittee
process what you need to understand is
the full cont context the full context
is this what you have before you here
today ladies and gentlemen you have a
piece of
legislation
that couldn't even get out of committee
with a favorable
recommendation it was
retained when it was retained there was
absolutely zero work done on it with
public the bill you have before you
amendment that was
defeated shortly after that this issue
was indefinitely
postponed for this Define contribution
plan okay that is because the history of
this issue in this state as it relates
to state state
retirees it makes no
sense the state employees aren't asking
for
it I don't see any of them here asking
it it boggles my mind it was also
mentioned that representative Wier has
has sent you testimony okay I know Ken
Ken's a good friend of mine known him a
long time 28
years I know that he had a defined
benefit plan and defined contribution
plan he did very very well well guess
what right now our state employees
basically have the same thing they have
their defined benefit
okay and they had their Deferred
Comp okay
403b so that's what they have right now
that representative wer had good for
both of them and you'll see now not not
not knowing what what representative wer
wrote but I've heard this testimony
before and I can tell you good for him
and good for all of us that our state
employees and representative Wilder have
both
um Karen irn mentioned a very good point
with this amendment um on lines three to
five and whether anybody really picked
up on it I know Karen did and she's
absolutely correct if you go to RSA 21
colon
I um 30 Roman numeral
2 that's where you'll see where the
state actually um pays for um says here
the state shall pay a premium or partial
premium for each Medicare eligible
retired employee and it goes on it's
really disturbing that with this new
plan that now um it's covered by
entirely by the group three
employee how are we supposed to recruit
people when that's the case when right
now they have what they have up with
right now under group one they have the
ability for the state to help them later
on in life with that
premium so I don't see anything in here
that
helps recruit any
individuals represented more I mean
excuse me um Mr Moore mentioned um that
he knew an an employee that had a
countdown had countdown for 10 years
when he was
vested basically what he did was he
proved the point that's retention right
there that's retention that's what we're
trying to do we're trying to retain
these
employees okay and of
course those of you who heard me say
this before you know who who really care
about taxpayer
dollars as you know under this proposed
plan taxpayer dollars go out the window
years one through 10 if somebody decides
to leave whereas right now it's
protected taxpayer dollars are protected
right now for those people that that are
years other than that uh I know the the
day is getting long and I don't believe
I have anything else to say um more than
happy to try and answer uh any questions
at this
questions don't see any thank you very
much for your appreciate you all thank
thank you madam chair my name is Tony
luckus I live in Hudson New Hampshire uh
it's good to be back for the committee I
was on this committee for four years and
I was a co-sponsor of a uh similar Bill
a couple of years ago and I'm just going
to try and quickly go through a number
of points that were raised and concerns
that were raised
um so there was some discussion of the
misbehavior or the bad decisions made by
the legislature in the past that's
gotten us in a bad situation
now um you know this would start the
process of insulating the state from
such bad behavior because once the money
goes
into uh the retirement plan um the the
legislature cannot mess with the money
that's already in there um so it's a
little bit of starting you know lead us
not into temptation I'd like to think
that the legislature would never do
something like that again but they did
it before so who knows we can't b a
future
one um there was concern raised by a
couple people about um the retirement
Health Care um my understanding is you
know with the bill and especially with
the amendment group one and group three
should be treated exactly the same way
so if you you want to provide it and in
both cases they're fully paid for by um
by the employee and if you want to add a
uh dependent to the plan it would be the
same charge um the the uh most recent
speaker raised no some other points that
um will have to be looked at there's a
number of things I'm not going to
address that uh concerns raised that I'm
hoping that uh can be addressed before
the subcommittee um but because I I
can't deal with them right
now another thing is there's a concern
raised um by a couple people about the
increase in cost to the state because of
the increase of the 2 and a half uh
percent to 5% of the state
contribution as I recall I could be
wrong but as I recall that was done as
an amendment to the bill and partly
because I think the committee just felt
bad about having such a low
um you know State contribution
but and certainly the committee here
could could bring it back to 2 and a
half% but the thing to realize is that's
how much we're contributing now to all
all of the the at least the group one
employees group two is maybe more
complicated um
so if that's that's a concern it can be
adjusted back
um there were concerns about um you know
the state group one becoming a closed
group and that causing um you know some
problems um
and you know the the retirement system
is trying to make predictions of what's
going to happen in the future and um you
know and set the contribution rates the
normal charge um based on that but if
they make a mistake either today with
the current group one or with this group
three then you know if they estimate if
the returns aren't what they expect Ed
or some other you know some of the other
assumptions they make don't work out and
result in uh less money coming in then
that's going to incre increase the UA
and thus the the cont the U
contributions paid for by employers and
that's true whether that mistake is made
with respect to group one today or this
group
three um it's one big pull of money as
as the nhrs people said now the way
they're doing the accounting they're
pulling it out separate and and so that
might make the error more obvious but it
doesn't substantively change the
economic situation of the retirement
system because that money has got to
come from somewhere and it's ends up
basically increasing the oal and thus
the payments from the
employers I think uh represented scitec
I think actually brought that
up um there were some
uh you know apparently alarming uh
numbers put out about the uh drops in
the stock stock market on particular
days particular days don't matter you
need to look at what happens over the
longer term retirement savings and
investment is a longer term
thing um I didn't we had the data two
years ago I don't have it with me
currently we'll try and bring it to the
subcommittee but you know even with the
terrible stuff that happened in 1929 if
you take a period of years over that you
know there's been a positive return um
and um you know some of these uh these
dips are seem dramatic but if you ignore
them things you know return to Trend
generally so there was uh statements
made that having the current system and
the vesting you know the 10year vesting
would contribute to retention well if
you look at the tiny percentage of
people that stay 10 years anyway that
apparently isn't working very well and
and um and there were statements that
well if the employees leave earlier then
the money some of the money stays with
the state which is true but I find it
interesting that representatives and
organization that are representing the
uh state employees would would support
in effect harm to the employees which is
really what's going
on
um when we had uh testimony before the
committee last time and then I had some
extensive discussions with some people
opposed to the Bill uh afterwards
privately trying to you know see what
their real concerns were and trying to
address those particular issues at least
in that discussion what it came down to
was concern that
um employees especially lower level
employees the ones that were you know
there was the DOT truck driver or
whatever uh would make foolish decisions
um with the
Investments and would end up with uh
with no retirement and um the way these
plans generally work is there's a
default um investment which is
um you know based on the time until you
retire your money is going to go into
some mix of uh stocks for higher return
and bonds for more safety and their
standard in the financial world and
retirement world there's standards for
that sort of thing and typically at
least my experience the default is going
to be something like that um and as part
of these usually you get
um you know you get there's some
education and other things and I don't
know they could look at putting other
restrictions on it but I don't think
that's the kind of problem that U you
know that they're looking at that it
would be such a problem that they're
looking
at
um and I will say that you know some
people have talked about the personal
experience I actually started out uh
with a uh a pension plan you know the
company I worked at I was there for over
16 years
uh before I left I was vested but
presented with the option of um either
eventually getting a pension when I
retired many years after that it was a '
96 or um taking you know the amount that
I invested in the plan and roll it over
to something like an IRA or another
401K looked at the numbers at that time
and I did choose to roll it over and not
get the
pension um I have since looked back at
that and it turns out that was a a very
good decision and I ended up uh
significantly better off as a
result
um so you know
that you know generally you're going to
end up and and most people I know have
ended up better off with a you know a
401k or IRA than uh actually having a
pension
system um and there there's really one
other one other one that I just thought
of um here is that and this you'd have
to talk to the state treasurer to find
out if this is true but not only is the
state currently have um significant debt
around the time retirement system we
heard like 5.2 billion um but as long as
we maintain the defined benefit plan the
state's at risk of that happening in the
future and that might you know moving
away from that to a defined contribution
plan might have a positive uh impact on
the state credit rating which would
actually save the state money in the
long run
um as I said there are other issues that
are raised that I I'm not you know not
in a position to address right now see
what could be done in the future but
that's all I have right now and if
anyone has any questions I'll make an
attempt at answering thank you present
Bailey thank
you you you alluded to the concerns that
have been expressed about group one
becoming a closed
system after group three is
created isn't this overall Social
Security System kind of analogous to
that that there's been a population
decline well it's become a Clos system
and actually not I mean there's still
more people being born going into the
workforce um you know and getting into
the social security system and the
social security system is
financially horribly unsound and that's
another whole topic though um and and
this system was hopefully we're in a
path to pay it off but that's always a
political risk I know when I was here it
was an ongoing battle to fight attempts
to
um to interfere with paying off the
unfunded liability I hope the
legislature of the future till it's paid
off is able to withstand those forces
but there's no
questions thank you very much thank
you is there any anyone else who wishes
to testify on House Bill
581 all right seeing none I'll close the
public hearing this bill
and House Bill 637 are going to the
pension subcommittee and representative
Lan will schedule work sessions as